okay four people joining the livestream
coming back after various vacationy and
trippy types of things we are starting
up a bunch of meetings again and this is
one of our infinite series of meetings
about incremental language development
for wolf language so let's get started
subset functions now I mean one question
about all of these utility functions now
is you know now that the function
repository is up and running you know
how does this stuff relate to what's
there and I've certainly seen some you
know recent function repository entries
that I have to say I I was saying to
myself gosh this would be a good
built-in function and I think we do
intend to have some kind of flow from
function repository to you know to
built-ins and so on
I mean like like for instance um if I
look at just the weekly digest here
people with me yes um you know like I
can imagine take after but that's a not
completely um but that's something that
I could imagine being useful and this um
you know position max thing you know
I've certainly used that a zillion times
exactly and that's one of the items in
today okay all right but things like I
mean who is who is trying to figure out
what then clearly the work going from a
function of posit or function to a
built-in function is can be quite large
but I'm just trying to understand um you
know who that's a nice idea this min max
rounded that's a nice idea um the useful
yeah the mean yeah this is another I
mean there's a bunch of things here
which were these are clearly useful but
they're not you know developed well
enough to be built-in functions
who who and how are we going through to
UM to analyze that question didn't think
we have mechanism yet it may be a bit
early perhaps once we see some functions
being used multiple times in other
places then you know you would consider
them for mmm-hmm yeah I have to agree
with that I mean unless we see something
that we just all say oh gosh why don't
we have this forever but well have we
seen any of those yet I don't think so
we've seen good functions but I don't
think any that hit quite that particular
chord okay
all right let's take a look then at the
subset functions is Tony here to
represent these functions
yes so these are like variations of the
sequence functions but with order of
less butter matching
why did you just say sort of the
sequence function oh I see I see I see I
said you saying I understand where this
isn't just cases I'm confused I think of
taking all the subsets of the list in
the first argument and then taking cases
on the result of subsets
but oh I see I see what you're saying I
see what you're saying so this is a
subset and but do you do it much more
efficiently than that yes I'm actually
using the bar cook very evaluator to do
some really efficient things in those
functions because I needed them for some
experimental new functions but will you
say the sparkle query evaluator is this
going out into some external form and
then coming back in again or is it it's
nicely so there is one common code base
that I'm using in three different places
and one of them all those sorts of
functions but so this is what is it is
it C code or what is it currently its
top level okay okay fine so the things
become really tricky and complicated
once there are more complicated
expressions that contain a couple of
named patterns in them then the seek the
order in which you evaluate or find
those patterns does matter that seems
like a mess let's say the same
glass subset cases example
you
I don't even start with that that is x2
why do you need these Tony why do these
come up so for instance in RTF
entitlement or rdf schema entailment we
are trying to find certain combinations
of triples that then entail an
additional triple I see
okay so subset sub property offers a
transitive property so if XY is there
and YC is there then is also X and C
it's interesting I mean there's a
this is actually bizarrely related to
these networks that are in my latest
fundamental physics stuff that was
really odd
yeah because you have essentially a soup
of triples and you're saying there is a
there is a threading through this soup
of triples yeah they can appear anywhere
how bizarre
you know this somehow there's never
anything actually new okay because this
case has come out of some all right well
okay so in this case then
right
so what this isn't doing is removing
those things from the soup right it's
just saying you are replacing those
things with this right
lettuce what subset replace will do it
takes order matching triples and inserts
the right insight you know maybe I'll
fly in here I can point you to the stuff
that was recently done for the physics
project that is an efficient
implementation of a bunch of things like
this um maybe
is-is-is sushma in this meeting maybe
you could connect maxime to tony and
take a look at that
you
well because this has come up in a
completely and utterly different way I
am more inclined to agree with it
right so this yeah right now I mean I
have to say that yeah all right - um
subset cases
so I see so this is threading through a
graph so to speak seeing how you get
from
yeah all right I guess I kind of agree
with these in non-trivial features if
you scroll down again if you were to
reorder all of those edges in the last
pattern now in an in a knife evaluator
you would plot the memory so there's
some topological sorting going on there
that evaluates this further efficiency
well that is interesting all right
you
so Tony in the case of overlaps is the
support in all their various cases of
overlaps apart supports true and false
for some pattern types so this is not a
full implementation just the cases I
need it from dysfunction so far
in some cases it's the different pattern
types need different implementations for
instance here you see just the case
where you have a fixed length Signum
subset yeah but you can use repeated or
repeated now that means optional like
elements here I get it but let's talk
about the overlaps thing for a second
so the issue is in for example subset
replace okay when you are there might be
many many overlapping
[Music]
I mean there's also imagine one could
imagine a subset replace list although I
think that's not necessary right now you
get what I'm saying um yes
so sequence replace for now doesn't have
any options related relating to overlaps
so I haven't considered them in the
subset case neither what what does
sequence the sequence cases have have an
overlap option yes so there are three
possible values yes they are we imitated
string cases
you know the fact that we have a -
greater than versus one of these
somebody could Devin are you you the PM
here did you point this out to Brian and
just say for goodness sake run a
cleaning pass on these yep
okay okay so what does all mean multiple
sub-lists that match the same pattern
are all included
Tony explained ya and in some cases you
could sing off a pattern let's say X
blank-blank
comma Y plank link their different ways
that pattern can match yes and even so
it's the same sequence that it is
matching yeah
it's binding differently I see I see I
see and is that what overlaps all does
is it deals with the different binding
cases as far as I understand yes so
basically it's related to replace list
okay so let's take a look at this one
here
so this is rather arbitrarily I mean
there's different ordering there
different things you could do here right
for for overlaps to true that is only
doing some sort of tower of overlapping
whereas this is doing the combinatorial
set of cases of overlapping that right
as this one D overlaps so to speak what
you're seeing is
right that's certainly not all the
possible overlaps yeah so in practice I
have used or needed the overlaps true
more because with overlaps for all I
wouldn't be able to draw more
conclusions at least in the case of RDF
reason so I just overlaps true words
overlaps true enough
by the way what are we doing when we put
it in the full language I mean the idea
of triple thing is specific to your
Sparkle subsystem right I guess you
could you can be modeling this perfectly
well with with lists and things never
mind
go ahead what were you gonna say what
why is it sufficient to do the this
overlaps true thing well it's a little
bit different difficult to explain so I
would have to go into the details of
their implementation
I mean to me it seems like your overlaps
case
wait are you saying that this is
overlaps true by default
yes I I followed the precedents of the
sequence fractions
and they have overlapped true by default
these follow the the present of the
string functions women sequence cases
has overlaps false by default yes this I
think the sequence cases and sequence
position string cases and string
position for some reason has a different
default and and this has been propagated
to sequence cases and sequence position
I'm a limit string cases you're saying
has default
to fault this overlaps to false okay so
you're saying string position has a
different default is that what you're
telling me yes if I remember correctly
that stickies and Taurus
I think this tried to use the the
setting which is most used for each of
the functions but I never understood
exactly why I think this was carefully
thought about I don't think this was
completely silly um okay so you're
proposing to face your overlaps defaults
on these that correct Tony yes I forgot
the details because of a some time ago
that I implemented it but I agreed with
those and I found them useful like that
all right okay okay so subset count is
kind of weird and probably not that
important but we might as well have it
yes cases positional count always form
touchable okay all right I find a
sequence count let's do it okay
so Tony I agree let's put these in okay
so these are for functions right 5 4 4 4
before yeah that's right
ok this is cool I mean there may be some
other issues but why don't you get the
thing you know put in documented etc ok
okay next up a very different topic um
taller history memory constrained yes
this is something you suggested and yeah
I think this is useful yeah I think I
sort of things to assign to the site
here right so taller history length just
starts erasing from you know the it
release erases both in lines and
outlines or only outlines good question
okay
all right so honestly history memory
constraints he was a lot more useful in
history length I mean I would never set
history like but history memory
constraint I could imagine setting
history link is something that we use a
lot to set to zero because yeah we want
to save as much memory as possible or we
are doing testing for no it leaks and
things like that but it rarely we set it
to 10 or something okay so here's a
question if you know in the modern world
where every cell has a UUID and all
these kinds of things could we imagine a
situation in which you please somebody
um
the anyway the the where where you are
sort of pushing it out to mass storage
if it's older you get what I'm saying so
I could imagine a situation in which you
would want to say those outlines that
are far in the past just save them in
files
but rather than keeping them in memory
maybe that's silly I don't know
come on so it seems like a second
iteration of this idea well I know it's
a second iteration of the idea but we
might as well get both iterations
let's see
the main thing I was thinking about is
whether we want to limit the total
amount of memory or the memory of each
of the in out like like saying don't
store the large ones
yeah well both of those are interesting
I agree that that one um
let's see
um actually we have a comment on the
live stream from Carl who's commenting
about the subset functions are acting
with data set did we think about that
could we lose Tony here sorry I was
listening Carlo my livestreamed asks the
question how do the subset functions
interact with data set
I don't think there's anything specific
to those functions no but I understand
but I mean I dataset in principle I
don't know whether what sequence cases
does for data set sequence cases could
work on data set I bet it doesn't right
now but data set can contain a the you
know a data set internally can be a list
of associations and things like this and
the question is can one use this and by
the way have you thought about how this
thing interacts with associations
because I can imagine you're I I assume
it just works where this audio triple
has for example a source and a sink in
an association let's say and those could
be in any order
am I making sense I think those
functions should work on the same heads
probably all or just lift like sequence
functions and give it a communist that
in data set you can apply a function at
any level you wish including those
subset functions which means they they
should naturally have an operator form
maybe together with the sequence
functions if that's possible
why don't you look at that that's a good
question I'm not sure but did you
understand what I said about matching
associations I think that will just work
would be an example well I mean this
this an example is is it match queue
well is do these the equivalence between
okay so let's do this
hey goes to 1 b goes to 2
versus
you
actually why don't we do happens if I
say random sample does this work
probably not was expecting a list um
oh it might work does this work
you
you
yeah okay does so if I say um I think
you mean front in choice no I mean
random sample and then I mean table of
that ten times that's just gonna give me
those in random orders okay
okay so now I want to say if I do
sequence cases of
am i confused here what I'm trying to do
is a sequence I'm trying to see whether
the sequence cases thinks that a arrow
blank a comma B arrow blank look so we
have a precedent from cases so cases on
an association works as if it was it's
values only
I think I think that's a starting point
okay but what does this do
does this generate does this eat early
that would require the use of key-value
pattern or something like that okay so
at least sequence position or subset
position could return the keys of the
Association as opposed to the industry
number indices
yes I understand all right well look
let's not okay so as you as you work on
these can you think about the
Association case yes Carl mentions be
nice drill to transform a dataset into a
bunch of RDF triples can you
that's possible but it depends highly on
how you want to model your data and
audio which means you have to choose a
vocabulary and then you can transform it
what does that mean so you call data set
and it's got rows and column row labels
column labels yes then you would have to
choose say what are the IR eyes for
those rows and column and yeah then you
basically have your triples do we have a
function that does that not yet because
that's not really automatic so there are
certain special cases if you have a
relational database like sing there's a
default mapping tool or DF and you can
customize that but for general Wolfram
language expression it's more difficult
fine all right let's go back to history
memory constraint okay so
I mean what you're proposing is a sort
of a simpler concept which is some kind
of dollar you know max history memory or
something or something like that I mean
you're saying what is the maximum size
of thing that you should store in an
output line and if it's too big I mean
that's analogous to what happens if I do
you know if I say audio capture um and I
just go you know Yakkity Yakkity Yakkity
Yakkity Yakkity yak hello hello hello
we're going on and on and on and then I
press stop there is a good chance that
that will be too big
ah still stored in wav file but that
could be too big to store in the file
right at the store
oh no there isn't now I'm confused
that's not in memory anyway right that's
in a file right but then say um really
big array or something that array of
what well you mean that that will hit
the too big thing and that isn't yet is
that yet unified with this you know it's
too big to store look data set has this
feature as well I mean if I say data set
of from range of like a hundred thousand
let's see what that does
okay but I don't think this has been
implemented yet in data set so Chris has
been working it okay what is this buzzer
ring
so try sparse array of that French okay
there we go
right
okay
well so that two different issues do you
store it
this is a question of the kernel storage
this is like the two big situation right
where you're not storing in the notebook
and this is exactly what two big should
do right it will say something like you
say range of ten thousand or something
and your great range or a hundred
thousand and you'll get this right and
this should say data not in notebooks
store now right because it isn't in the
notebook is it
no I think so it is your thing it is in
the notebook it is not right moment if
we save is easy
we cannot recover it later right so this
should work and insertion right sounds
to me like this is related some of the
projects that you were were managing I
don't know whether Devon has taken those
over um but this should in this case
here it should have a thing just like
this that make sense yeah yeah and I and
I think we're having a meeting later
today about this exact issue not the
deal yeah yeah like just in general okay
fine fine because that's the consistent
okay so what we've got
um
you
let's see
we've got two different issues here
we've got does it store in the notebook
and then does it store in the kernel
because those are two different issues I
mean you could store in the notebook and
not store in the kernel or store in both
or store in either make sense
right they are independent right so an
output line
okay
well that's kind of weird that you could
have a situation in which you say out 75
and it'll be not stored in the kernel
but it is stored in the notebook
in other words let's say your colonel
died you could actually recover out 75
from the notebook true or not true yes
but we can have that situation now with
history length serum and in things that
are printed in the screen I understand I
understand but we're not trying to do
that recovery now at all right I mean in
fact more than that as soon as the
colonel dies we get rid of all the
numbers which I guess we have to do no I
mean but in the modern you you ID'd in
the modern case okay
in the modern case where every outline
has a UUID
part of % modernization okay it is the
case that we could in fact go back and
sort of go back and and recover
something that was there in a previous
session previous colonel session right
hmm definitely so we actually have
independent several independent things
going on here we have
right so we've got a colonel history
thing and we're gonna say if it's bigger
than such a such a size don't store it
in colonel in Colonel history now if it
was semicolon in the notebook you're out
of luck it's not gonna be in the
notebook either right but if it was too
big it might be in the notebook okay so
I think this is for Devon to comment to
take to parth about notebook you know
sell you you IDs do you understand what
we're talking about here yes okay um all
right
the
you
I think the main thing here is a way to
control memory in use because memory
loss typically grows a lot by the
history right but I mean the simplest
thing is don't store it if it's bigger
than five megabytes or something right
and that's easy easy to understand
because if we have a global limit it's
kind of difficult to predict which ones
are being stored and removed well except
that one way to look at it is I just
want a reasonable history but if it's
gonna go crazy just start dropping it
but I agree I mean what would we set the
default
what would we advise people to set the
default to for a single thing 10
megabytes or something what I mean cuz I
probably by default would say should be
infinity yeah but yeah default it should
be infinity but I mean um
you
see if they don't do that then things
like graphics a typical graphic can be a
few megabytes
right look I think there are two cases
here I mean there's a maximum size for
an individual element
you know this is some kind of dollar max
hoped memory except that's obscure
and as you said this should control also
the in because perhaps we have very
large inputs yeah okay so perhaps it's
math.max history cell memory or but not
cells well what's the in outer do they
have to go together I don't think they
have to go together I mean you know we
could imagine this
item memory okay so what does it do so
that you set that to a megabyte and
something is beyond that what do you get
back I think what you get back is an
unavailing outline do you agree I think
you get a message in a none evaluated
outline
what's that well I mean so you say out
a85 I say that I get that value yeah
that's what I think
Keystone networks sorry
okay does history length generate a
message if you are accessing an outline
that was there but has been removed no I
think so I think it just returns out
Eddie
I claim it should generate a message and
I think this should too
I think it should generate a message
saying this outline was dropped because
it exceeded the history element memory
limit so the message is when you try to
access it later no incorrect it's God's
correct if you try to access it later it
says sorry it's not there because bla
bla bla so I think this is pretty
reasonable any objections to this I'm
still a bit confused about the aim out
because sometimes the out is very large
because the in was very large fine kill
them both I mean this is a separate item
this is that they're separately
controlled so if the in was huge and the
answer was 17 then there's no reason to
get rid of that outline see what I'm
saying um
now actually it's an interesting
question
I think there's no choice if you have
okay there is a bizarre case but I think
it's a bad case which is you've got an
icon eyes in line that's huge
but icon eyes doesn't offer you any
don't store it in the notebook option go
what I'm saying arguably I can eyes
should be able to pull things in from a
file see what I'm saying I think that
will be a nice feature I mean I don't
think it's the most urgent thing but
right so in other words you could icon
eyes a bunch of images for instance and
they could be actually pulled in from
files so that's related to the thing
about having notebooks with indirect
referencing of assets you know just like
an HTML page has indirect referencing of
for example image assets did you get
what I'm saying I think I understand
that that looks more difficult to
implement and probably we would need
other people to discuss that no I
understand I understand okay let's go
back here okay so I think we've agreeing
Mac's history element is that the right
name um is that the right name perhaps a
note instead of element
no because it's it's in or out that's
really confusing
well we do have dollar line don't we yes
so we could do something with that
mm-hmm kind of kind of obscure max line
memory it sounds like we're talking
about the old days of telephone lines or
something
you
you
comments on that max line memory I mean
it does go along with dollar line now
that is a little bit unclear on whether
it means in in or out
perhaps in the front end that is a
terminology some terminology for for the
two components of a sell the inning out
no I think it's just in and out I mean I
think it's I think um inputs/outputs
alum okay look I don't know whether this
is should be called history item memory
history element memory or max line
memory and so on but um Devon can you
please make sure there are notes on this
and then who would get to implement this
you know perhaps don't you is it is it
in the front end space I guess it is I'm
not sure I'm not sure if this is more I
don't know that has to be reviewed okay
now again that perhaps it would be nice
to have some sort of mark in they note
that some grain or something that
denotes it has been removed how do you
know which ones has have been removed
how do you know what dollar history like
well you don't but somehow he still
liked this simpler because it's not a
matter of well but you should it should
work the same way and the answer is very
simple we already know the answer the
answer is the same as the answer if I
kill the session which is that you get
those deflated in out labels you see
what I'm saying
I see without a number well those ones
don't have a number but they also
deflate as in they go italic and they go
gray I see so I would say we would leave
the number here because it's still the
same session but it would you know
visually deflate so to speak
and you could imagine a situation in
which the in line for something is left
on the outline is not
look I think that's what we do we
deflate the thing we have a mouse over
for the in outline that says it's been
removed because of because it's too big
um makes sense yeah and then this is one
of these I can't believe we got away for
30 years without having this I mean I
guess that's because people just set
dollar max dollar dollar history lengths
um
what are we going to call this what are
we going to call this
history line max memory that's a
confusing with respect to the amount
thing
somehow the history doesn't play much of
a role here because it's I mean in the
other case is history because it's from
this moment to the past oh well here
it's more like an independent thing of
the other selves so what are you
suggesting here I'm wondering whatever
the world history should be there or
what else could we give it line
tor I mean I'm still thinking that in
out should be there somehow
it's a little weird
because in or out right well we can
certainly consider that as you know
let's get it implemented and as it's
implementable think about this but but
then
okay so here this would be now let's
talk about the total case the case where
you just say I want to use 200 megabytes
but I don't want to use more than that
um
right so those are 200 megarace total
for the or all of the ins and the outs
right and so then you have to kind of
heuristic Li guess what to drop yes so
it's a trade-off between recency and
size
what is the obvious way to do that
II I guess we store if we obey all of
the constraints
I understand but I mean as you as you
add something in the issue is that
particular line is only a megabyte but
it puts you over the edge
do you drop the new line no you do the
least recently used
oh you dropped the least recently used
but you could easily end up in a
situation where you fragment and where
you could be dropping we you if you had
no in the future you would have dropped
less so I'm saying because you could
drop can either drop dropping a big you
know five separate lines each of which
it's quite small when actually you could
have dropped only two of those lines
based on what comes in the future yes
this is what there is a comment there
from Brian and he was basically
suggesting same thing
what is he suggesting one simple idea is
look for the biggest for the bigger one
and then drop from that one to the past
but that could be too many perhaps all
of the other ones to the past of that
one are very small
yeah I don't think it's good I did just
say go every time as a big lump drop
everything before it that seems wrong if
that's what you're suggesting I think
what we'll wants to do is look there are
two parameters how recently was it used
and how big is it right so the question
is what is the optimal thing to do given
those two parameters what is the optimal
way to achieve a certain level I mean
why am I reminded of these you know
efficient frontier portfolio analysis
type things somehow it's the same type
of problem I think there's a there's
sort of a standard um
you know
you
um am I saying the standard um hey look
look can we please think about that
question is there a standard an obvious
way to do this nothing that I
immediately know but but you know you
just got to think about it it's it's
you're filling in you've got these two
parameters right you've got a you've got
a plot it's got how recent was it how
big is it right and your goal is to you
know color that plot right in such a way
that you have the the best
in some sense the best coverage making
sense yes I think the goal should be to
maximize the number of in outs that we
keep fine or maximum number of
independent ends and outs that we keep
okay well if that's the goal
you
right I mean whenever there's a really
big one you probably want to throw it
out but again I I'm pretty sure that
somebody who knows about optimization
and so on knows the answer how best to
do this
so can we please ask the optimization
crowd Robbin people like that okay we
have a couple of suggestions from Brian
on live stream history memory size
history item memory size
not crazy
do we only care about history what about
like large cell prints and or copying
pasting into a notebook well those
aren't stored in the kernel anyway I see
just pure notebook things um
look that's okay we've got it we got a
path forward either in our memory I
think this history memory size is not a
terrible one memory
am i storing this this
well somewhere
what do I not need to so everybody got
that have you got the the notes of this
yeah I have it already yes okay all
right I'm not gonna store it then okay
let's go on to the next item
um actually we had some other comments
on the live stream ah complaining about
the find dialog in notebooks yeah that
thing is absolutely horrible that's just
terrible I mean that's a question for
parth what the story of that is I have
heard comments about how it's beginning
improved but I you know and there's also
the question of does it even bother to
look at these absolutely giant cells
right
it already is silent here maybe we
should get part if we're gonna discuss
this any further okay Devin for you to
let's not do that today right now but if
let's ask him what's happening with the
fine dialog expect to discuss that in
the user assistance meeting sure okay
okay some cons from call about data set
to RDF interesting to have automatic
vocabularies for quantities entities
those are great function repository
functions and Karl you are highly
encouraged to contribute to the the
function repository um ok Ethan is
asking about ordered associations and
also unordered
let's see what what are we having right
now we have
that whole business about ordered
associations and unordered associations
that was the original plan was to have
multiple ones of these things but it got
so hairy um I mean it certainly would
not get its own you know special angle
bracket syntax and so on I agree that
that's the thing to discuss we should we
should put that on the it's probably
related to Tom's new raw data structures
project and perhaps Stellan perhaps you
could make sure that that gets added to
that discussion and also make sure that
we get a meeting about that project
please as soon as tom is back yep okay
all right let us move on here we can for
a little bit um okay table while
yes here I think the main question is
whether to follow while in which we have
a test expression or to follow the
length nest while exception in which
there is a criterion function sorry
what's the difference yes so in the
first group we have a criterion function
which is testing each element that it
finds
while in while there is a condition
which is sharing the variables with the
body and then it's general for example
there done implemented a simple case in
which the condition is a condition on
the iterator for example yes but it's
not a fine time that is applied to the
result of table
I understand I mean this will be nice is
this multi-dimensional is this only
one-dimensional
I think that's only one dimension it has
one iterator but in general the
interesting case here would surely be a
case where table you know where you have
a ragged
boundary to this multi-dimensional array
okay what I'm saying yes so if the
condition is going to be only on the
iterator then somehow we can do it in a
you know like that other example there
we can select from the range the cases
of the iterator that we want and then
just past those well I understand and
the multinational case is over hairier
than that yes but it still could be done
take problematic cases when we want to
have a condition in which we involve
both the iterator and the number that
was generated the element of the array
yeah we want we want to do we don't want
to do the select anyway one of the main
ideas here is to reduce memory footprint
at least sure in my learning and okay
where did this table wildthing come from
anyway it was a suggestion from I think
so so and you wanted to have some sort
of general way of controlling iterators
perhaps to be an option perhaps well the
issue is you know keep mapping so for
example one could have a I mean with
scan one can certainly have a scan with
a return in it right no I mean a scan
yeah so you can do that hash is greater
than for return you know a hundred I see
what you mean that was the result yes
yes
now
what is the case for table
you know it's kind of like keep
generating these this table until the
numbers get bigger than a million and
then stop the most common case is going
to be that the condition is on the
generated thing because if the condition
was on the indices you could you know
just do that in advance exactly yeah so
I think this is more like length wine
list while with a criterion function
rather than yes I agree now it's also
the case that table multi-dimensional
table while
I mean yeah so what would what would map
well do its mapping F surroundings until
suddenly chokes and it stops doing it
which is kind of weird
get what I'm saying
right I mean you say and for 1 F of 2 F
of 3 F of 4 and then 6 7 8 right me the
question is whether we'll return also
the remaining elements or not perhaps we
just return the ones mapped I see
and table with yes in the multi mention
twenty dimensional table the interesting
thing is how do we return only one level
we could stop at one level but continue
at the previous one what do you mean I
mean I I'm confused by what I would do
go ahead yes I mean I was trying to to
understand your rugged case in which we
have for example a collection of lists
and then each one will decide when to
stop
examples stopped each row when the
element gets bigger than something and
not just stop the whole matrix Karl is
quoting something on on mathematical
Stack Exchange about how complaining
that we have nest while and nest well
list but we don't have fold while fold
well list
let's talk about that case for a minute
yeah that case seems rather
straightforward
because that case is essentially a
criterion you are feeding values in from
the folding source so to speak right
yeah and this is the termination
condition for that yes and again we need
to say what to do with your remaining
values nothing you're done I mean just
like nest while gives you know in the
case of nest while once once you failed
the criterion you're out of there so
similarly with fold it has a supply
through I'm saying yes but with nest we
don't have a list of length a million to
start with no I understand but you can
think of fold as having a supply list
and you can decide sort of um you know
discretionarily how much of that list to
use yeah yeah and so then fold while
would just say well it fails the test ok
stop using the supply list and that does
seem rather straightforward that case
and I agree I think we should definitely
do that fold well forward list I mean
obviously one day we'll get into fold
pair while list but that's even more
ornate worry about that right now
something I'm noticing that we use test
for the boolean expression and sometimes
for a function perhaps we should make
this homogeneous and call it great I
think we probably should yes I agree
with that cuz this is confusing here I
was immediately confused here
that's a Brian assume if we can
inventory where that happens I agree
with the conclusion though but okay but
back to okay so fold while fold well
lists are fairly straightforward they
would work just like this basically ok
so then we've got
and we've got take while right now right
yes so the question is is there a table
while that's really what remains on the
table here so to speak um
okay so take while also has the story
that at some point it chokes so to speak
oops um
you
all right so at some moment it just
stops taking so the obvious our log of
that and table would be it keeps going
and its supply is what's specified in
the you know index range but at some
point it just says oh I'm I'm done and
stops so in the univariate case it seems
to me that that's fairly clear it will
be a table with a crit
yes problem table is where ogz will take
also his work
I see
so this is a one-dimensional version of
take
right well I mean look in the case of
the table it has this weird question of
what does its frontier look like in the
one-dimensional case is rather
straightforward in the multi-dimensional
case both here and for table it's kind
of obscure
okay what does the frontier look like us
what we were discussing before right how
much I how much Jay got done so in this
case they wanted to have a just break-in
I think it would be kind of weird if if
the iterators did not behave like
standard iterators for do and and table
and etc but what's your point your point
is that there's an implicit ordering or
what yes so you don't really question
yeah yeah yeah right exactly
and I think its outermost first Barry's
feel most rapidly if I'm remembering
correctly but yeah um well it's the
flatten ordering basically it is the
order in which way you to unravel the
thing into a flat version that would
define an ordering correct yes
but perhaps stable while should be also
one-dimensional I'm not even sure what
to put there criterion argument if we
make it Bernhard well obviously that's a
problem
I mean syntactically that's a problem
functionally it's unclear we could make
it the first argument that's not we've
done elsewhere
certainly not would take well I Packer
nice by the way
you
I have this feeling that we should get a
table while one dimensional table while
at least in the function repository and
see what it's like
meanwhile I think fold well farewell
list are you know things we should be
doing ah ah hummons on the livestream I
the suggestion for a meanwhile
what just kidding yeah it goes through a
list of things and as soon as there's an
outlier it gives up yeah exactly
um okay table while working with
parallelized whoo interesting no I don't
think so
well I mean it's basically the animal is
a parallel try isn't it with parallel
eyes you have all sorts of ordering
issues you know the order of the result
but you don't know the order in which
things get done I understand that but
but table while think about it table
while if it has a crit right and the
crit is local right because the crit in
the case of nest while the crit has this
rather complicated thing that allows
look back okay so I'm saying so this is
em the most recent em results as
arguments see the recent means proximal
though and this does not play nice with
parallelizing I understand that but if M
is 1 then this is perfectly
parallelizable will be at a bit of a
waste of time because you might be
probing you might be doing trying a
value out you know far out in an index I
think that I'd like to view these as
short-circuit operators kind of like the
boolean's and an or etcetera so there's
a quick short-circuit that says when
you're done and that you don't evaluate
things after that short-circuit that's
sort of an important notion in computer
science and I think that these should
follow well that's a side effect there's
no side effect who cares true now
further then it's a waste of time but I
still if you've got a lot of parallel
processors you know time can be wasted
well I guess the question I will raise
is do we want to regard these as short
circuiting or not if not then
parallelizing is fine it's a good
question I mean it should certainly be
addressed it's not obvious to me that we
need to I think that there's enough
squiggle room in parallelism like
parallel table for instance doesn't
right now preserve you know if I say
parallel table and in that parallel
table I've got you know print so coming
if I do that right now right right right
now it's gonna go the wrong thing
almost certainly if I say print I I mean
unless it refuses to parallelize I don't
know I up to 10 and we'll see that is
super ugly by the way and that really
needs to get fixed well I'm actually
completely impressed look at that how
did it do that how the heck did it do
that
turn on channel 12 first how did it do
that
I'm not saying what you're saying I'm
gonna help my full screen I have a full
screen sad can't can't cannot see this I
can now see one two three
I'm sorry can i yeah okay so I don't
understand how that worked unless it
somehow didn't that is just totally
weird look did you see this two people
see this I don't get them in order I get
one three five six two four really yep
oh you know what it is let me go up to
20 I think it's gonna fail when yep yes
yes the reason is because I have 12
cores on this computer this counter that
I don't even understand why that worked
but the counter the number of cores is
larger than the number of cases that I
was evaluating
well so you know to be honest this has
already crossed the bridge right the
parallel table here has already
determined that
no meaning to the evaluation order if
there's a side-effect in one of these
well of course this is a separate
parallel table and one can imagine a
parallel table while in which case the
rules for what gets evaluated when and
how the side-effects work right hey I
would not have an expectation of a table
function short-circuiting or you know
forcing an ordering of the evaluations
whereas a table while I might have such
an expectation
maybe I mean you know this is the
question of
if okay I think that's a separate
question but I think the issue of
whether I mean I'm I'm beginning to
think the table while is primarily a
one-dimensional concept
I do think that this is a perfectly
reasonable thing like give me all the
Fibonacci numbers less than a million
right that would be an easy you know in
this table while set up right with with
the critérium with hello Fibonacci of n
you know well then but then what I'm
doing is I'm saying I mean how do I say
what is the best way to say what I do
there here is to say hash less than a
million for example right but I'm having
to commit myself to the size of the
iterator which in a sense shouldn't be
necessary but what will be the
constructs that were I would get if it
is a pure right
I could imagine in this case since it's
in fact that this would be the more
natural thing to do
well we could have ankama infinity
because you may be also interested in
getting 100 at most a hundred like your
say it except well I agree but this case
that I just wrote down here
which is a different sort of
degeneration from the case of table
where the table in the non list case of
table is just giving that number of
identical elements
but this case seems somewhat interesting
to me
I just keep going as a function of n
until you I mean in a sense that's more
what I wanted before I think here we may
heed the discussions we had with table
itself about having braces or not do you
remember then that there were problems
about yeah I'm ready to do well well in
the end we don't have braces for the
case where it's just table and thank
goodness be done that was a horrible you
know syntactic you know awkwardness what
for the numeric case yeah this case here
yes and so I'm saying that for the
symbolic case and there are these issues
of whether angle value eight to an
actual iterator yeah giving the
evaluation semantics well I mean if it's
table while the evaluation semantics
could be different from table yes that's
good look honestly this seems pretty
useful to me really quite useful yeah I
would also support income infinity oh
sure yes that's fine too
could you could you scoot it over to the
left I'm on full screen and I try I
don't know what you're doing I see it
now I'm working on a Linux box is what
I'm doing I'm suffering like our users
at least the Linux ones that's not a
problem that zoom doesn't doesn't show
you the right-hand side of the screen on
Linux true way that means they're like
your winnings and suffering it's the
little systems um okay
the I really like this really like I
think we should have this
yeah I think it's good to have this one
dimensional and it fits take one now am
I correct that the criterion can just
reference the iterator explicitly no it
should be able to know the criterion is
just on the values it should Danny is
saying is that the the what can happen
is that it does a binding of the
interact what is that background noise
come on that's my office mate I have to
be able to speak though for this
particular conversation I've been you
good about using new ok ok so anyway
that this is you know so what we're
saying is this case here that the N is
bound before the before the thing is
evaluated I see
I'm still a bit concerned that I I mean
are you trying to exclude the N comma
100 notation or oh I'm not I'm not I'm
just saying that you can degenerate
instead of degenerating into a constant
you know just repeat the first element
which is kind of useless in this case
I'm saying the you know the sort of
singleton second element the second
argument means this just that's the
iteration there it starts at one
increments by 1 and goes until told not
to yes yeah that sounds fine
and if you really want you know for
example you could do this if you wanted
to you could say n comma zero comma
infinity if you really want it to be
zero origin sure well you can also give
a skip right in anyway so I think I like
this design here so let's try to do this
okay okay okay I think we're running out
of time here um let's just look ahead at
some of these business
these is the question of whether there
is an applied version of the head map
which will be useful for multi-argument
functions so head map we had agreed on
yes yes even with its name okay we
didn't have violent disagreement we went
through many many other possible names
and then came back to head map yes I
think head map was the least bad names
or something okay so what happens if we
have functions of multiple arguments
which are not natural
with Matt but they are
well you're suggesting that head map
beaver arcs it's a bit weird it's a
possibility because it's like construct
then exactly but none of none of our map
functions is vark in that sense no I
understand
you
you
I mean head apply seems to me to make
more sense than they you can just
achieve that same result by just list
putting them in a list right
scene is much more controlled the virág
head map just seems you know
increasingly head explosion okay you
know the force of that um so to speak I
think it's hard to understand I I agree
that had applied does seem like it's
useful unless
I see no you can't really do that I mean
otherwise what you would be doing is
each one of those will be apply it would
be a mapping apply onto the F sub I so
what I'm saying and here we would you
would say you know head map I mean this
is this this is just getting into the
utter obscurity apply mapped onto F 1 F
2 F 3
if I'm not mistaken XY there would be
correct right because apply f on to list
XY does that
right nothing so you know somebody
should have in terms of these sort of
educational weird things I mean somebody
should just like there's all this
functional programming the ways that
these functional programming things
combined it's a I don't maybe that's
what they teach in functional
programming classes I have no idea I
doubt it
they probably something much more
Elementary anybody nevermind
um a comment by the way from ether on
livestream make sure that nest fold map
while interact well with dynamics why is
there an issue with dynamics
I'm not sure why doesn't a suit hum
okay well look I think head apply
is okay and this is the discussion we
were having at the beginning this is a
function that I sing it's a resource
function already but it's requested
it may be worth having a system I think
it will happen now again raised the
possibility of having it being
multi-dimensional and that gets more
powerful but a little bit more
complicated because precision is very
general it's fully symbolic well max
requires numeric expressions well I mean
you're saying position largest by
effectively
it's very similar to take largest
already but